not that we needed more examples of huge
corporations using Donald Trump's
corporate tax cut to pump up the price
of their own stock but we have another
example and it's Texas Instruments they
make those remember those graphing
calculators from high school and college
that you could sometimes install Tetris
on and instead of doing differential
equations you were actually playing
Tetris much to the ignorant of the
professor which of course now is common
that's what everybody's doing on their
laptops at this point in college at the
time it was kind of novel the company
that makes those graphing calculators is
Texas Instruments and they spent 5.1
billion dollars repurchasing shares of
their own stock that is twice the amount
that they spent the year before and more
than any other Texas company in the S&P
500 index it just so happens that under
Trump's tax plan their tax rate their
effective tax rate dropped from 39% in
2017 to 17% in 2018 overall companies in
the S&P 500 saw an effective tax rate
decrease of 7 percentage points on
average and tons of those companies are
using that extra money simply to pump up
the price of their own stock by
repurchasing shares which benefits as
I've told you before their shareholders
and their executives the richer they are
the more they benefit from pumping their
own stock Texas Instruments wrote in
their 10k filing that quote our strategy
is to return all free cash flow to
shareholders which is in black and white
a very different strategy than using
money to hire people using the money to
increase salaries using the tax cut for
all of the types of winning that we were
told would come from Donald Trump's tax
cuts now Texas Instruments did make a
modest increase to their capital
expenses some of which would be
reasonably said to fall under the
umbrella of reinvesting in the company
but it's small potatoes compared to the
billions that went into just buying back
shares of stock and it's one of those
stories were yet none of it is
surprising like if you were paying
attention this is exactly what we were
predicting this is what always happens
and it's going to get even worse check
out this chart comparing hourly wages to
products
what you might notice and I'll describe
it to you is that up until about 1973
wages and productivity went up basically
in parallel as workers became more
productive their wages went up roughly
in proportion to those productivity
increases and then in 1973 that splits
and hourly wages go up only nine percent
since 1973 while productivity is up 72
percent now this is partially technology
and this is why the interests of workers
and their employers are no longer
aligned for lots of companies their
biggest expense is wages for employees
to increase their stock price they need
to cut expenses or increase productivity
without parallel increases to wages and
that is exactly what they're doing and
it's only going to get worse with
technological automation destroying more
jobs machine learning is going to
destroy jobs artificial intelligence is
going to accelerate this and there's a
really good book I'm reading right now I
believe the book is a year or two old
it's called life 3.0 by max tegmark and
it's all about machine learning and
artificial intelligence and much of it
focuses on the impact on jobs
I really recommend the book but none of
this is surprising and when you zoom out
it's not surprising that Donald Trump's
tax cuts are not boosting the economy so
much that we're making all of the money
back that we are giving in tax cuts
Trump said yes the tax cuts reduce
government revenue but they will
stimulate so much economic growth that
then we would make up for that it's not
happening the debt has exploded the
deficit has exploded and there boy
therefore has grown the debt even more
quickly and every element of this was
predictable all along none of this is
surprising if you're surprised by this
you either weren't paying attention
don't understand how this stuff works or
we're deliberately pretending like it
was going to go differently under Donald
Trump than it has every time in American
history that this type of economic
policy has been adapted through the tax
code tell me where I'm wrong make sure
you're following the david pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show and
follow me on instagram as well at David
Pakman some very good
behind-the-scenes videos from the studio
that I posted yesterday that people are
extraordinarily titillated by check
those out one of today's sponsors is
impeach the card slap game
you cannot slap Donald Trump in real
life but you can slap him in this
hilarious fast-paced two-player card
game and you can get it for ten percent
off when you go to david pakman.com
slash impeach and use the coupon code
pakman show at checkout all one word
awesome for parties when you're having a
few drinks I've been playing it with
some friends of mine currently has a 5
out of 5 star rating on Amazon and it
combines clever satire about the Trump
administration with really funny
high-quality cartoon artwork all in a
really lively card game that's easy to
learn but it stays interesting every
time you play it because of how well
designed it is and really how much
thought went into the humor and the
political commentary the game covers a
ton of themes global warming Russian
collusion tax cuts for the wealthy
impeach the cards slap game is perfect
if you're looking for something fun and
casual to do with your politically
minded friends or family members you
might even learn something new about the
Trump administration while you're
playing the game it's a perfect gift for
anyone who has a sense of humor about
Trump or get it for yourself and have a
really fun and witty game to play when
people come over you can even play a
tournament style get impeach the cards
slap game by going to david pakman.com
slash impeach and get 10% off when you
use the coupon code pakman show at
checkout all one word